[Music]
if you guys remember a while back we
talked about New York's new bail reform
law where instead of I remember people
do you want to explain it like you can
go I just wanted to say I know okay I'm
glad you said of holding people that
can't pay their for their vehicles are
too poor so what they're doing now is
that if you are arrested for a
non-violent crime you no longer have to
post bail before your trial or like your
your court date or whatever oh cool
yes yes they can release you without
posting bail because it's not my
nonviolent thought that went into effect
January 1st and there is this man named
Charles who's 56 years old he has been
arrested six times he's a start of the
year and he's like celebrating he's like
he'll reform her lid she's like thanks
to the it's the Democrats Democrats know
me and the Republicans fear me you can't
touch me a cabbie stop hey what's the
crime that he doesn't steal internet or
something no so what he does a man or
what so what he's doing is he's a career
criminal and so he will do subway goers
by dressing up as MTA officials and
robbing people after offering them to
like to help them buy like their metro
card but if it's nonviolent RZ robbing
them likes because the because if he's
gonna be helping them get like a metro
card he takes the money and then it runs
off yeah oh thanks running off with
people's money and she's also like
jumping that it's not violent yeah yeah
it's not violent she's a scam artist
yeah so that's he's pretty much
celebrating how he's like see I'm famous
I take two hundred three hundred dollars
a day of your money people come up with
these laws thinking that it's gonna make
things better and then it ends up where
criminals do what criminals do which is
exploit the [ __ ] system I don't know
why people do this it's so stupid so
this is what he looks like
oh wait man one thing let's make the
laws easier for people to commit crimes
and which guy is this guy this is the
guy that's celebrating the fact that you
got arrested six good for you man take
it take it and go Thanks
are me innocent people well they're kind
of stupid to wait if they're old ladies
hey old lady should have got street
smart you're a new yacht true you've
been around long enough right you
should've known better
yeah if you're battling the older you
are the more I expect out of you because
I'm like why the [ __ ] are you acting
like a six-year-old child that's never
lived a day of their lives
what if there's six year old children
then then it's okay yeah they should be
with a parent but the old ladies who get
scanned online because they click on on
the thing that says you have a virus oh
and they call that [ __ ] number my mom
no we're also gonna be talking about it
lady that almost got scan later today
you guys keep hitting these articles
before we talk about oh man that's
enough on crime that I would like
somebody to definitely and not could not
get bail for cuz that shit's [ __ ] a
con artist yeah yeah yeah this guy he
has been arrested 139 times crazy but
six times since the start of the new
year but he just continuously gets
that's just a little racket yeah so how
come he hasn't like gonna actual like
jail for just you know this is what he
has this is rap sheet okay so he has had
several stints in state prison he has
six felonies eighty-seven misdemeanors
twenty-one missed court hearings and and
yet so he was like a career criminal he
keeps getting away with and if he runs
away from you and you can't catch him
you deserve to get jacked that guy looks
so slow like he doesn't look like a fast
runner I don't know bro he's pretty thin
he could be one of those like six like
he could be a long just long distance
yeah look his cheekbones how did it talk
he's slow I can't even see his legs no
no he looked older though AJ never man
he looks like a long-distance steady
pace guy he doesn't look like a spring
guy could be one of those six year old
guys who are who have really good cardio
looks like the type of guy that would
wear like short running short well here
he is jumping the turnstile
and also if he's robbing if he's getting
if he's scamming people on the Metro
right maybe he gets the money right
before the doors closed and he just runs
out and then so yeah yeah you'd like
hazard down the system he also looks
like he runs fast enough for his
hairline to get pushed back oh maybe
that's what it is
well maybe that's a that's a part of the
plan he looks like he could be like a
dad on our old 96 combo he's definitely
using his look to help him with this
game sure he looks legit yeah yeah I
believe his what are you saying yeah I'd
give him my money true I'd be one of
those idiots who gets had by him that's
me he gets easy dresses like a NCAA
official too but can't you guys smell
the con no like when someone comes up
and it just don't you get the feelings
like you're trying out right no what's
the con exactly he's going yo the
machine's not working you can just pay
me and he grabs a runaway or he'll be
like I can help you ma if I'm like lost
in [ __ ] and I look like there's some
people that look lost his [ __ ] and I
look lost and then he has a uniform he's
like hey I can happy to be like this
uniform is probably off by a little bit
you know I have another with the [ __ ]
they could just be aggressive
aggressively trying to help you see
that's my rape feeling yeah so like for
example like when we were in Italy like
this happened to Casey where he was
trying to get a train ticket those
weirdos all these people just are
surrounding him and they're like oh here
will help me so horrible he was like no
no no but then it was karate-chopping
no no no his old lady there that was
like the one being forceful and then
there's like really huge guy came behind
us yeah why don't you go shh shh well I
wasn't there but also this is New York
yes so it's like there's probably so
many tourists taking the train first
time they have no idea what's going on
you know because as soon as we got off
the airport in New York a guy was like
you want to cam right I've got a cab for
you man I was like I'm getting a yellow
cab [ __ ] you man
this signs like one of the guys that had
the shirt button all the way have down
in gold chains and rings and she's like
oh
for you minute he's a guy who talks
about how he's Italian every three
seconds yeah [ __ ] get it you're
Italian they have the black cars they
always have the black cars I mean those
guys won't they will take you where you
want to go but it's like I never do that
don't know what no matter what any
country you go to like I never trust the
person hustling cab rides people hug
it's a good deal let's jump it [ __ ] bad
half a dozen Bahamas we land and there's
this guy who has like a little I don't
know what his car was like a little like
a black black Cadillac wooden thing mmm
uh and he's like he's like do you want
to come you know with that taxi [ __ ] you
want you want some of the you want some
of this [ __ ] you want riding styling on
my knowledge of a [ __ ] anytime someone
compares there's to the legit and you'll
want the legit okay this guy's shady
exactly like what twenty dollars cheaper
than yellow guys and you're like yeah
right
yeah I was like how much he's like 120
I'm 120 if I can go to go like 12 miles
in your cool car yeah yeah dude those
are spider senses man I get off even
when I don't know the language yeah
that's true you could I got conned in
China wait how did that happen if you
could let her since I was telling my
friend the translator cuz I can't speak
the language as his other friend was I
was like they're gonna [ __ ] us dude and
he's a he's a rich boy that doesn't have
spider senses he's a wallet they're
[ __ ] my wallet Han but they didn't
get it because I already preemptive
strike that [ __ ] what I told I
told him I was like all right get ready
I was like grab your bags and get ready
to run they're gonna [ __ ] try to con
us you're like wait what do you know oh
you know I'm like don't have a [ __ ]
debate with me exactly dude like sit
down they're going like this right now
what do you thinks about to happen yeah
and him soon enough they started arguing
about the price the tip the service and
he's like yah he just [ __ ] [ __ ] me
they overcharge me and I'm all like
[ __ ] I don't even know the
language and I knew what they were
conspiring to do it's obvious when I was
in Jamaica and I was crossing the street
from the hotel to the beach right and it
was this dude he was like and he was
like oh what do you need you wanna tour
you toured a whole island I'm like nah
I'm cool man he's for blah blah blah and
he's like man he's like ganja you want
guns
you're like cool man even smoke he was
like women you wanna women I find you
women I'm like I'm here when I'm here
with my chicken her family I see his
cool and he goes cocaine good like you
some user a bumper cars okay
no cocaine keychain meanie go magnets
for you hey you got some silence [ __ ]
away from me damn you got some in there
yeah but you also don't want to anger
them because you don't know how many
other people are like watching with
knives in like that's true
they're there to rescue you know yeah
yeah so weird the Bahamas and it seemed
a little shady that could go to a liquor
store just because I don't want to spend
like crazy amount at the resort big deal
yeah I get the deal and you get there
and the guys are like oh no no no you
don't wanna go to this one go to the one
through the background like oh I wasn't
born [ __ ] yesterday but then the one
that I was going to had an open get and
it took like 15 minutes and I was like
damn this guy's not here yet it's
supposed to open at 10:00 a.m. I was
there at 10:00 a.m. that's why you was
telling you don't go to that what it's
right most so then I'm like all right
[ __ ] it
I'm not paying these resort fees or
[ __ ] crazy yeah so I go through the
dude you're not supposed to know but I
was like [ __ ] I was like I don't have
much on me I could cancel my cards I'll
figure it out so I walked through the
back and sure enough there was this
hidden liquor store in the back he was
right I was real one
yeah that sick [ __ ] in it too you're
like you're trying to con me yeah he's
just a nice guy that's like hey stupid
it's open this was open right now and I
was like yeah sure like yeah I've been
in there it's a drug store and he's a go
to go in the back and I'm like yeah yeah
yeah the back
yeah he's news being tight he's [ __ ]
peddling his moustache and she
but you know it's like so it's like even
though you were trying to protect
yourself and you were wrong like you
can't even come off and be like oh I'm
sorry man like I it's like you go trip
thing too because they're like [ __ ]
can't admit that I didn't trust you
he well he probably knew he probably
knew I didn't trust him because I wasn't
exactly like I was exactly like that I
was gonna wait for this one I would have
said it out of like my bad did I just
didn't trust anybody
most people know not even kidding I left
my phone in there on the glass table
because they have this glass table with
like marijuana shouldn't it too and and
I left my phone in the glass table and I
left full on left and right I was it on
my phone and it was right there still
[ __ ] honest people honest good honest
people in the shady room
do you guys ever feel like you want that
validation from a condo there's me and
David with me right now we were Paras me
and David were like we're just kinda
like oh maybe maybe they'll try to trick
us cuz like oh you want to be tricked
Lucas Michael got scammed your mom
levels got pickpocketed like we were
just never targeted and I felt like what
is it about us that's not what is what's
going on they're already reading your
body language so they look for the most
successful ray and people that are the
most oblivious to what's happened is
smart and probably Michael is like oh
damn this hooker has a gun
[Laughter]
[Music]